say you're out flying kites with a
friend and right at this moment you're
40 meters away from your friend and you
know that the the length of the the
kite's string is 30 meters and you
measure the angle between the kite and
the ground where you're standing and you
see that it's a 40
40 degree angle and what you're curious
about is whether you can use your powers
of trigonometry to figure out the angle
between the string
and the ground and i encourage you to
pause the video now and figure out if
you can do that using just the
information that you have
so whenever i see a i guess a non-right
triangle where i'm trying to figure out
some lengths of sides or some lengths of
angles
i immediately think do i maybe the law
of cosine might be useful or the law of
cosines might be useful and so let's
think about which one could be useful in
this case law of cosines and i'll just
rewrite them here the law of cosines is
c squared is equal to a squared plus b
squared minus 2 a b cosine
of theta and so what it's doing is it's
relating
it's relating three sides of a triangle
so a
b
c
to
an angle so for example if i knew two
sides and the angle in between them i
could figure out the third side or if i
know all three sides then i could figure
out this angle
but that's not the situation that we
have over here we're trying to figure
out this question mark we're trying to
figure out this question mark and we
don't know three of the sides we're
trying to figure out an angle but we
don't know three to the side so the law
of cosines doesn't seem at least in an
obvious way that's going to help me i
could also try to find this angle but
once again we don't know all three sides
to be able to solve for the angle
so maybe law of sines could be useful so
the law of sines
and the law of sines
so
let's say that this is
this is the measure of this angle is a
measure this angle is lowercase b
measure this angle is lowercase c
length of this side is capital c length
of this side is capital a length of the
side is capital b
law of sines tells us the ratio between
the sine of each of these angles
and the length of the opposite side is
constant so sine of lowercase a over
capital a is the same as the sine of
lowercase b over capital b which is
going to be the same as the sine of
lowercase c
over capital c
so let's see if we could leverage that
somehow right over here so we know
we know this angle and the opposite side
and the opposite side so we could write
that ratio sine
of 40 degrees
over
30.
let's see can we say that that's going
to be equal to the sine of this angle
over that well it would be but we don't
know either of these so that doesn't
seem like it's going to help us
but we do know this side and so maybe we
could use the law of cosines to figure
out this angle because if we know two
angles of a triangle then we could
figure out a third angle so let's do
that so let's say that this angle right
over here is theta we know this distance
right over here is 40 meters so we could
say that the sine of theta
sine of theta
over
40. this ratio is going to be the same
as the sine of 40 over 30 and now we can
just solve for theta multiplying both
sides times 40
times 40 you're going to get let's see
40 divided by 30 is four thirds
four
thirds
sine
of 40 degrees is equal to sine of theta
is equal to sine of theta and now to
solve for theta we just have to take the
inverse sine of both sides so inverse
sine of
over 3
sine
of 40 degrees and put some parenthesis
here is equal to theta
is equal to theta and that will give us
this angle then we can use that
information this information to figure
out the angle that we really care about
so let's get a calculator out and see if
we can calculate it so let me just
verify i am in degree mode very
important all right now i'm going to
take the inverse sine
of
four
thirds
times
sine
of
40 degrees and that gets me and i
deserve a little bit of a drum roll now
58 well it's just right it's well it's
very close if we round to the nearest
let's just let's maintain our precision
here so
58.99 degrees roughly so this is this is
approximately
equal to
58.99 degrees
so if that is 58.99 degrees what is this
one well it's going to be 180 minus this
angles measure minus that angle's
measure so let's calculate that so it's
going to be 180 degrees
minus this angle so minus 40
minus the angle we just figured out and
actually i could get all of our
precision by just typing in second
answer so that just says our previous
answer so i get all that precision there
and so i get 81.01
degrees if i want to round to the
nearest let's say around around to the
nearest hundredth of a degree then i'd
say
81.01 degrees
so this
this right over here is approximately
81.01
degrees
and we're done